vamos a practicar un poco más sobre cómo
encontrar el ángulo de un cierto vector
en este caso el ángulo positivo que se
forma a partir del lado positivo del eje
x y el vector en forma estándar es decir
donde su punto inicial o su cola está en
el origen bien aquí tenemos a este
vector am al cual podemos escribir en
dos formas distintas la primera
anotación le ayuda mucho a los
ingenieros y también se le conoce como
la anotación ingeniería es decir tenemos
a menos dos por el vector unitario y eso
quiere decir el vector unitario en la
dirección x y después menos cuatro por
el vector unitario j
es decir el vector unitario en dirección
james
otra forma de verlo es decir bueno su
componente en x es menos 2 y su
componente en james es menos 4 y lo
podemos ver justo aquí si estamos en el
origen y caminamos 2 unidades a la
izquierda y después 4 unidades hacia
abajo
entonces llegamos a la cabeza del vector
y llegamos a su punto final así que es
momento de encontrar el valor de este
ángulo t como vimos antes cuando tenemos
vectores vistos en su forma estándar
podemos decir que la tangente la
tangente de este ángulo theta es igual a
la componente y entre la componente x en
este caso es menos 4 / menos 2 menos 4
entre menos 2
recuerda esto lo vimos en el vídeo
previo
explique por qué llegamos a esta
expresión es decir vimos que viene de la
definición de las funciones
trigonométricas que obtenemos con el
círculo unitario tangente de teta es
igual a la coordenada james entre la
coordenada x del punto el donde se
intersecta el círculo unitario y la
línea que define el ángulo y te encargo
que veas ese vídeo si no te suena todo
esto entonces vamos a decir que la
tangente de a este ángulo teta es igual
a bueno 2 o dicho otra manera te da va a
ser igual a la función inversa de la
tangente que se denota así tangente a la
menos uno de dos y voy a poner aquí un
pequeño sino interrogación y estoy casi
seguro que sabes por qué lo estoy
poniendo pero bueno así que si traigo la
calculadora por a camps y bueno me voy a
tomar la función inversa de la tangente
voy a poner aquí dos y fíjate que no me
estoy tomando la tangente me voy a tomar
la función inversa de la tangente es
decir cuál es el ángulo cuya tangente es
2 y si yo le pongo aquí me va a salir 63
puntos 63.4 si lo redondeamos así que
aproximadamente este ángulo teta es de
63.4 grados y voy a mantener aquí es
decir nueva interrogación que estoy casi
seguro que tú ya sabes por qué es y sin
pausa el vídeo y piensa un poco el por
qué estoy poniendo aquí un signo de
interrogación porque este ángulo cp
sospechoso bueno pues se ve sospechoso
porque un ángulo de 63.4 grados estaría
viviendo en el primer cuadrante estás de
acuerdo si mi lector se viera más o
menos así si mi vector se viera más o
menos así
algo más o menos así podríamos estar
pensando en un ángulo de 63.4 grados es
decir si tuviéramos como componentes 2n
equis y 4 el jem tendríamos este ángulo
de 63.4 grados que sería justo este
ángulo de aquí pero no estamos en el
primer cuadrante estamos viviendo en el
tercer cuadrante así que creo que te es
claro que estamos en la dirección
opuesta y creo que ves el porqué cuando
tomamos la función inversa de la
tangente nuestra calculadora siempre nos
da resultados que están entre los menos
90 grados y los 90 grados pero en este
caso tenemos un ángulo que está más allá
de los 180 grados están entre los 180
grados y los 270 grados así que para
hallar este ángulo y ojo ten cuidado al
usar la función de la tangente inversa
en tu calculadora es
importante que pienses en cuál va a ser
tu ángulo
si estás hablando de vectores o algo así
es importante que pienses en donde
debería estar viviendo tu ángulo es
decir en qué cuadrante estás y con esto
ajustar tu resultado entonces no va a
ser 60 y 3.4 grados va a ser 60 y 3.4
grados más 180 hasta llegar acá así que
te está va a ser aproximadamente ojo no
va a ser igual porque tomamos un
redondeo en esta cifra va a ser
aproximadamente 180 más 60 y 3.4 grados
lo cual nos da 200 ok 80 más 60 es 40
240 y 3.4 grados de lujo ahora si éste
es nuestro ángulo theta y de lujo vamos
a hacer un ejercicio más este de aquí
aquí tenemos un vector en el cuarto
cuadrante y te encargo que justo como
hicimos en él
otro ejercicio francés el vídeo e
intentes encontrar el ángulo positivo
que se forma a partir del lado positivo
del eje x
bien podemos hacer lo mismo que hicimos
aquí de hecho hasta nos podemos saltar
algunos pasos porque ya lo hemos hecho
muchas veces sabemos que teta es igual a
la función inversa de la tangente de la
componente y que en este caso es menos 6
entre la componente x que en este caso
es 4 es decir que te dan va a ser igual
a la función inversa de la tangente de
bueno si hacemos la división es menos
1.5 así que es buen momento para traer
de nuevo nuestra calculadora y hacer esa
operación vamos a borrar todo y vamos a
tomar los 1.5 negativo ya esto le voy a
aplicar la tangente inversa esta de aquí
y me va a salir menos 56.3 así que voy a
notarlo
ángulo theta parece ser aproximadamente
menos 56.3 grados y de nuevo voy a poner
aquí un signo de interrogación porque
este ángulo que nos están dando es
negativo como vamos a encontrar la
versión positiva de este ángulo ahora
bien observa esto si nosotros empezamos
en el lado positivo del eje x y
caminamos esta vez a favor de las
manecillas del reloj vamos a montar
justo este ángulo de aquí el cual es
menos 56.3 grados pero espera nosotros
queremos el ángulo positivo entonces
como lo podemos obtener bueno pues hay
un par de formas para obtenerlo una de
ellas es decir para ir de este ángulo
negativo a este ángulo positivo observa
que tenemos que dar una vuelta completa
para llegar a él dicho de otra manera lo
que tenemos que hacer es sumar 360
grados
entonces el ángulo que estamos buscando
va a ser aproximadamente bueno este de
aquí menos 56.3 grados más 360 grados y
bueno cuantos esto si subo un poco más
mi pantalla voy a hacer esta operación y
puede decir que esto es aproximadamente
bien veamos 300 360 le quito 50 me
quedan 10 días 10 le quitó 6 me quedan 4
pero aquí hay un punto decimal entonces
va a ser 300 3.7 grados vamos a
comprobar si yo sumo 3 y 7 son 10 y
llevo 16 y 17 y 3 son 10 y lo voy a
sumar a este 5 más 1 son 6 y estos no
quedan en cero y después de sumarle 300
me quedan 360 grados de lujo así que
aquí lo tienes aquí tenemos la versión
positiva del
ángulo que forman este vector ven a
partir del lado positivo del eje x y que
acabamos así que te recomiendo que
siempre pienses con cuidado lo que en
verdad te están pidiendo como respuesta
nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo